je m'appelle millésime j'habite à Lyon
je suis artiste je suis venu à côté de
Dijon dans la ville de Chenôve pour
réaliser un concert on a refusé de me
donner les clés soi-disant donc il y a
un arrêté municipal nous interdisant
d'aller dans la salle je ne suis pas au
courant mais on va faire le concert ici
j'ai une grande scène comme vous pouvez
le voir vous serez intégralement
remboursé ok qu'on soit bien d'accord et
aucun souci là-dessus là il y en a
[Musique]
vous allez en prendre connaissance vous
pouvez le dire vous-même
interdiction du concert de millésime la
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme et des libertés
fondamentales du 4 novembre 1950
messieurs bonjour monsieur le Président
vous allez bien
et toutes les discriminations voilà on
doit lutter contre tout ça après moi si
un jour je décrète ce joueur de foot du
Paris Saint-Germain j'ai des crêpes que
mes partenaires s'ils sont pas chauds je
joue pas c'est mon conviction personnel
est-ce que ça doit empiéter sur la
conviction collective en fait
[Rires]